yeah hi everyone and thank you so much
Antonia for the introduction
um I also want to speak out a very warm
welcome to everybody and also since you
found your way to this talk I want to
offer my condolences to you because
probably the path to this talk was very
painful but this is a safe space and
hopefully you're gonna walk away with
some of your pie torch trauma resolved
so we're gonna talk about how to debug
pytorch models today in a structured
Manner and as you can see from the title
already honey I broke the pie torch
model breaking a pie torch model or any
machine learning model in general is
usually something that happens by
accident and is not easily reversible
and the reason usually is that our
models consist of many complex
components that also work together in a
very complex way so if something is
broken our model is usually still
running and we see that something is
wrong but it's very very hard to
identify what is going wrong so today
we're going to build a little toolbox on
what to do when you see something is
definitely wrong with my model but I'm
not sure what and also go to some
applications
but before we dive in I want to give a
very quick introduction about myself my
name is Clara Hoffman currently I'm a
PhD candidate at kleinelab which is a
research lab at the research center for
trustworthy data science and security at
the University Alliance War and in my
research I mostly focused on Beijing
uncertainty quantification for deep
learning especially for quantifying
predictive uncertainty on computer
vision applications I also worked as a
machine learning engineer in production
at the startup called life EO which is
also based here in Berlin where I was
working on computer vision applications
with synthetic aperture radar data which
is a very special type of data you can
find the slides to this talk on my
GitHub and if you want to know more
about me you can also check out my
website or my Twitter
so let's get right into it first of all
I want to get everyone on the same page
with a quick reminder of what our
pytorch models usually consist of and so
for most of you I think this will be
pretty clear already we usually have a
trading and validation data packaged in
data loaders we have our model structure
set up which we train with our training
Loop we obtain a fixed rate model and
then we usually have some prediction
data loaders and obtain predictions
so what can actually break in the setup
we have three components that are very
susceptible to breakage first of all the
model structure usually this is just a
stack of layers and basically what can
happen here is I accidentally delete
some layers forget to connect some
layers
um more obvious mistakes like wrong
dimensions are usually already called by
pi torch
the next component that can break is the
training Loop the training Loop
basically passes the data forward to the
model and then propagates the loss what
can go wrong here for example wrong loss
functions propagating the loss in the
wrong direction
we also have our data loaders what can
happen here for example we accidentally
only return the same batch in each
iteration
but actually if we look at these
components our model does not seem too
complex we only have three components so
if I'm debugging basically what should I
do okay just check every single
component mm1 should work right
the main issue when we're debugging High
torch models or machine learning models
in general is that
we usually see that something is broken
but not what is broken because when
we're training we're not really seeing
what is going on in these components
what we're usually observing is only
validation metrics or training metrics
like our loss or some accuracy scores
um and let's have a little example of
why it's really really hard to identify
what is going on in our model only from
these loss or metrics
so I have a very small example here a
very simple model structure that you
would probably not use in your
day-to-day work just to linear layers
and a non-linear activation function and
I train the classification model
um on some classification tasks with the
small model so on the right hand side
you can see the loss curves for my model
yes I know they have not converged I
just chose some arbitrary number of
epochs you can see the training loss and
the validation laws going into the
correct direction and now we have our
little breakage toolbox here in the left
hand corner and we're just going to look
at what happens with our loss when we
break a couple components of my model so
first of all let's freeze the weights
well this looks as we expected the model
is not learning anything the red curve
which indicates the losses of my broken
model are just stagnant
second let's freeze our bias
okay actually we have a Buckner model
but our last curves seem pretty good
actually so here already we run into
some issues we will probably not be able
to see that there's a bug in a model
from our lost curves alone let's break
our data loader to always return the
same training example okay here we can
already see something is going really
really wrong
um the training loss is going steeply
downwards and our validation loss
upwards so we heavily overfitting on the
training set here
and now let's break our activation
functions so I'm just getting rid of my
relu here and this is quite interesting
so the red loss now looks almost the
same like in the scenario when I had
been freezing my weights
um so this is a very important issue
that by just looking at my loss curves I
can see that something is wrong but not
really what is going on and then my
whole trouble basically begins
so what are the main problems when we're
debugging models first of all bug
entanglements
um usually I don't have a single bug but
in several of my components and when the
bug is in something like my data or my
data loaders basically I have no chance
to retrieve my bugs without going really
heavily into my code
the second factor is that when I'm just
going to my code fixing things and then
running my model again this is usually
not very efficient because for example
if I have a bug in my data loader I will
never be able to perform any good
training because my data is just not
having the sufficient information to
train a good model
um it's also pretty hard to prevent bugs
so for example if we had the idea okay
I'm just going to use some software
engineering based tests to prevent bugs
in the first place
um this is not really working well
because software engineering is a very
static framework whereas machine
learning development is very flexible so
usually if I want to introduce software
engineering based tests this is more
harmful than helpful in machine learning
so what can we do to overcome these
issues I prepared a little debugging
cookbook for you and it basically has
three components and our main takeaway
here is that we want to isolate each of
these components to make sure that we
identify any bugs in our error
so the first component is our data
if something going if something is going
wrong in our data or data loaders we
basically have no chance to train a good
model so a very good approach is to
create some simple synthetic training
data but I think most of you don't
usually do this because creating
synthetic training data sounds quite
bothersome the second component is our
model and we're going to look a bit at
how to create project transferable
pre-trained tests to make sure that
everything in our model is working the
way it should be before even starting
training and the last component is the
interplay between the data model
basically when we have made sure that
our data is working well our model is
working well but we still see that
something is not really right and here
we're going to look at some project
transferable post-train tests to catch
any last bugs that we might have in our
model
so let's start out with our first
component the data and I want to start
with a bit of a um yeah image that is
not evoking positive emotions for
machine learning Engineers here we see a
domain shift between synthetic data and
real data and usually this is not
evoking positive emotions for us because
usually we're creating synthetic data to
pre-train a model and then we see our
real data is actually completely
distant from our synthetic data and we
cannot generalize with our model
now I want you to forget any
associations you have with this image
when you're debugging because when
you're debugging you actually love this
image because this tells us actually our
synthetic data can be as simple as
possible if we just want to train a
model that is bug free and cheap to
train
we don't really care about realistic
looking data we just want to reduce our
data to the most basic learnable
characteristics and if we have a domain
shift occurring between the synthetic
data and real data we actually don't
hear about this so one of the main
questions I asked I like to ask myself
when I'm creating synthetic data only
for debugging is how would a minimalist
artist depict my data
and of course when we're an artist we
kind of have to find our style we have
to kind of find out okay like how simple
can my data be how difficult or
realistic does my data have to be and
we're gonna find this out in a little
case study so we're going to start out
with a negative example I think this
will be very standard to all of you
basically my goal would be to train a
classification model and I would think
about okay like how simple do I have to
make my data or how simple can I make my
data so my first idea was just to would
just be to generate from three gaussian
distributions and assign each
distribution a class so this would look
like this here I have my data points and
the colors are the labels and this data
looks fine
so what happens if I simulate some
breakage in my pytorch model so here on
the left hand side I have a very simple
encoder again with two linear layers and
one non-linear activation function so
let's see what happens when when I break
my activation function
so on the right hand side you can see my
good model in blue and the red model is
my broken model without activation
functions and this looks quite good on
first lens but actually this is exactly
what I don't want so I'm seeing that
with my synthetic data I cannot even
catch a very grave mistake like missing
activation functions
so what happened to you of course if you
look at the data my data is linearly
separable so it can perfectly be learned
by a neural network without any
non-linear activation functions so this
is already the first lesson don't make
your data too simple they definitely
have to be some non-linearities in it
and to check that I'm also telling you
the truth let's look at another example
with non-linear data which I just
generated with scikit learn here I think
these concentric circles are well known
to everyone in machine learning and but
in general you can basically create some
non-linear data with any combination of
non-linear functions
um so we again have our model here let's
break the activation functions
now this looks much better my model is
broken and the loss also looks broken so
this is one of the first lessons if
you're making your data make sure that
your data is definitely non-linear
so I think most of you are also thinking
this example is way too easy this is not
what I'm dealing with in production and
this was basically only your first
primer as an example because when you're
creating actual synthetic data the data
will be heavily dependent on your use
case
now I want to go into a more complex
example um which was inspired by my old
work
so let's assume we are working for a
computer vision company and we want to
identify changes in Harbor activity and
we all know managers are very very eager
so they have set up a big project very
ambitious we want to monitor Harbor
activity over a very long time period
let's say 300 time steps based on
satellite data so you can already
imagine it will be quite hard to find a
data set like this on some repository
that is perfectly labeled and also cheap
so of course the first issue is that
there are way too many time steps the
second issue is that if we would
actually buy and label this data this
would be extremely expensive
but when we're at the company usually we
will obtain this data at some points but
we might already want to start training
our model and make sure that it's bug
free
so how could we create data for this
case I want you to think of the question
again how would a minimalist artist
um create or recreate this data and
actually I think most of you have
already done this in a game called
Battleship or shifting in German where
basically we just have a little square
and draw rectangles as our ship
so here is my little shipbuilder that I
would use
um to debug my model and already train
it and basically I think this is a
really nice example because we can
generate our whole training set for
debugging with just two functions
basically what I'm doing here is I have
my ocean and then I have a little square
which is my ship and with my functions I
can basically generate arbitrary many
training examples with different numbers
of ships different ship dimensions
and this only and just two functions so
I have my one function which generates
my rectangles or my ships uh basically
use your samples coordinates of ships
and then my second function basically
just only iterates over my number of
ships and then returns my image so even
though this data set does not look like
a real satellite image it's still very
very useful for debugging my model
because it contains all the basic
information that I would need for my
actual model and the other Advantage is
I can basically generate any label that
I would also have in a real use case
from these functions because since I
generate the ships must have I already
have the positions of the ships
of course I think most of you will work
in very different fields so I just want
to introduce some other packages for
creating synthetic data of course you
don't always have to do it by hand I
think especially in computer vision it's
quite handy to do it by hand because
it's very intuitive
um but yeah for other applications for
example there's the times used generator
and python with which you can generate
time series there's also a package
called plate Pi which I think is very
interesting
um especially if you want to fill up
some databases so basically here you
just have to create a yaml template with
different variables so for example we're
generating a person here which has the
variables age and gender and I can
specify some distributions or some
Maximum and minimum values
um in computer vision if what I've shown
you is too simple for you there are also
some more complicated or more advanced
packages like Zumo lab zpi where you can
basically create the objects you're
interested in in blender which is a 3D
rendering software and then
automatically obtain labels
or if you have already created semantic
masks like we did in the shipbuilder you
can also use scans or the fusion models
to basically generate synthetic images
from your segmentation masks alone
so let's have a little checkup on our
debugging status we have talked now
about the data components how to create
synthetic data in a very simplistic way
to make sure that our data component is
definitely isolated
next we're going to go to the model
components
and I had already mentioned that I want
to introduce the concept of pre-trained
checks here but I know that maybe some
of you have quite a negative attitude
about tests and machine learning
um and this is usually because we tend
to use software engineering testing
workflows for machine learning
development but this is actually not a
good idea and I want to go a bit into
detail on why this is the case
um so here on the left hand side you can
see what is going on in the typical
software engineering workflow basically
our customer or our managers wishing for
a feature we developed a feature the
unit has passed and our project is
basically finished so if we would like
to apply the same framework to machine
learning engineering we will train our
model then we would have some predefined
Metric like 90 accuracy that we want to
reach on some test set and then our
project is finished
I think if you're working in machine
learning you already see several issues
with this so first of all this kind of
pre-assumes that we know which model to
train which is not always the case
second it kind of presumes that we know
what kind of accuracy is reachable on
our data but usually our real world data
is very very messy and also some clever
machine learning Engineers will
definitely find some workarounds on how
to reach this 90 accuracy without
actually creating a model that's useful
so what can we do instead to make tests
and checks useful for our models let's
look at the machine learning development
cycle so usually how our development
cycle looks like is we have an idea we
experiment and based on the outcome of
the experiment we either have to start
our cycle again or if we are succeeding
rewrite our unit tests and then deploy
our model
but we are basically going to be in this
Loop usually a couple of times and most
of the time it's going to spend in the
experiment stage so this is where we
need the most support
and a very useful way to use tests and
checks here is that we have something
like a machine learning test Suite which
basically offers assistance during the
experiment phase and also helps us speed
up our experiments by preventing the
most common bugs
so let's look at an example of a machine
learning test Suite I want to show you
this package called torch test and it's
basically a single function call which
you can run before your model so these
pre-trained tracks that are offered in
this package for example test for output
ranges invalid values and also how the
variables or parameters in your model
are updated there's also another version
of this called the torch check package
which is also quite useful you can check
it out and I have a little example
prepared here with this function so
advice change there are many more
functions here
um
and here our model is set up so we have
very simple inputs and very simple
targets and just build one batch with
our data and then we have our most
simplistic model here which is not even
the model just one linear layer
and how do you use this function
basically we call the function input our
model our loss function our Optimizer
our batch and our device and what will
happen in this function is if the
weights are not updated properly so for
example if you had accidentally Frozen
your weights or biases this function
will fail and your training will not
even start so this is a really nice
component that you can just put in front
of training your model to make sure
nothing is going wrong and you're not
finding it out after spending a lot of
money on AWS
um there are also some functionalities
to check the output ranges for example
if you have a sigmoid in your last layer
and want to make sure okay I'm really
getting the output from my thick mode
and not accidentally from some other
layer before
and for this you can basically set up a
test suite and then specify the output
ranges and also set
um Define that you want to test your
output ranges
so these are just some examples but what
would
um what would the ingredients for a
successful ml test Suite in general be
um if we look at the data loaders we
want to test for data leakage to make
sure that nothing from a training set is
spilling over to the validation set we
also want to test for in-batch variants
to prevent that we accidentally always
returning the same training example if
we have some subsetting happening on our
data loader we also want to check for
data ranges and invalid values and of
course we also want to check for the
data format that it has the appropriate
input or output shape the same way for
our models we want to check for weight
updates output ranges our performance
and usually what is also a bit more
complicated to to construct but very
very helpful is that our model should be
able to overfit on a trivial case like a
single training example
another very important ingredient of the
machine learning test Suite is that
usually you don't want to place your
test in the same repository as your
project so from software engineering
based testing we usually have this setup
where I have my my package and I have
some script called train model here for
example and then I would set up a test
folder where I have a testing script for
each script that is present in my actual
package this is not really helpful for
machine learning because you will
basically end up writing the same tests
over and over again and this is just a
little bit of a waste of time also it
kind of brings the danger that you're
over engineering your tests to the model
that you're currently trying out and
this is not really what we want from our
machine learning tests a general rule is
that if you can't transfer your tests
from Project to project you have not
written a helpful test for your machine
learning test Suite
instead we would like to have a project
independent test Suite which could look
like this so we have our tests here and
then we have our tests or checks for
different components for example the
data loader the weights or also
expectation tests for example if I
assume my model to be invariant to
certain input changes and then when we
have built this test Suite we want to
import it to any specific machine
learning project
so let's have a little recap on what we
talked about so we figured out the data
components our data should be definitely
fixed now we figured out the model
components so we should be able to catch
approximately 80 or 70 of our box that
don't want to overdo it now
um but still because machine learning
Engineers they're very very creative
um I'm pretty sure we managed to
introduce some other bugs to our model
as well
so I want to go a bit into post-train
test
which kind of look at how the data and
our model
interact together
so I want to start off with a post-train
test in this package called Weight
Watcher
so Weight Watcher basically is a package
which gives you metrics for your newer
Network without having to have access to
your training or validation data so even
if you have made some grave mistakes in
your data loader that you couldn't
identify or your data wasn't even
containing the information to learn a
good model in the first place you will
probably see this with Weight Watcher
so I want to show you one very specific
metric that this package provides is
called the alpha value and this value is
computed for each layer in our model
basically what the meaning of the alpha
value is that we compute the weight
correlation Matrix which is basically
just the matrix product between our
weight matrices for each layer and if we
plot the eigenvalues of this Matrix on a
histogram
we want the tail of the histogram to
adhere to a power law and this power law
should have exponents to so this is
quite complex but the only thing you
have to remember is okay I want my Alpha
to be A2 and if I see it at any other
values especially values above five this
indicates that my tray here is not well
trained
and you can find some more theory in
this paper linked here so let's look at
our Alpha value and how it looks like
for our different breakages so on the
right hand side you can see the alpha
values from my unbroken model and
according to our Theory these values are
quite good so they are around two and on
the y-axis you can see the count so this
means I have one layer with Alpha value
let's say 1.8 or so
now let's break our model a little bit
first of all let's break the activations
and here I can already see my Alpha
values are definitely higher than with
the model that's working properly
now let's break the data loader here I'm
now seeing some serious issues one um
yeah one alpha value is very very close
to four already which like our alarm
should be going off a little bit now
I've reached the weights this is a bit
counter-intuitive but I think it's from
the fact that if I freeze the weights
they're basically stuck at their random
initialization
our model almost looks better than The
Unbroken model
and now let's freeze our bias and here
again we see that our unbroken model is
a little bit better than our broken
model
so this is a metric that is quite
helpful for comparing models of course
it's not able to tell you everything or
also points to exactly what is going
wrong but the it can be quite helpful if
you really don't have any access to
training data or validation data or if
you have serious trust issues to your
data because maybe you don't trust your
labelers
um another Post train check I want to
show you is from a package called
cleanlab
um here we basically want to find out
whether any examples that we have in our
data are mislabeled
um when we have already trained the
model so we don't want to go through our
training examples
um step by step but we want to see this
in an automated way this package also
has a lot more functionalities for
example
to inspect consensus if you have
multiple data annotators and also
provide scores if you don't want to
label all your data but you want to have
some Active Learning mechanism to label
your data and of course also to detect
outlier out of distribution examples if
you have the suspicion that these are
present in your data and
yeah if these are present in your data
and you want to get rid of them
so for Miss labor classification we're
using a concept called self probability
the main intuition here is that we're
just looking at the class course that
our classifier is producing which I
think is pretty straightforward
and the nice thing about this package is
that you can basically input any trained
Pi torch model into this package you
just have to make sure that you
transform your pytorch model to an
fklearn object afterwards I just have to
run this function where I input my model
my training data consisting of the data
and the labels and then here I say okay
I want to have the predicted
probabilities to guide um
to guide the
the suggestions of which of my data
examples are mislabels and then
afterwards I can have a ranked list of
indices in my data set that are probably
mislabels so this sounds very nice but
maybe let's see how it works in action
so I have my beautiful concentric
circuits here again and on the right
hand side you can see my loss curves for
a simple classification model
and now let's mix up some labels
so now you can see there are evidently
some blue dots in the Inner Circle which
should be red so this is definitely not
correct and on the Outer Circle I have
some red dots which also should not
appear there but at the same time in my
lost plots I'm seeing okay if I mixed up
my labels my performance is a bit worse
but it's not really something where I
would say okay I really need to go into
my data and look at it again now let's
run cleanlab and actually I think this
is really really nice of course it's a
simple case but cleanlab almost
identified all the data points that I
have corrupted so when there's a green
circle around the data point this means
that cleanlab would suggest me to look
at this example again and potentially
relabel it
I think only two examples have not been
identified so there's a little red dots
lost here not identified and a small
blue dot here somewhere which also
shouldn't be there
now let's wrap up everything how would I
set up a robust model training pipeline
so that I'm reducing the potential for
bugs as as strongly as possible
first if I'm not 100 sure that my data
is perfect so unless you're training on
mnist or something similar you should
consider creating some simplistic
synthetic data and keep this rule in
mind okay how would the minimalist
artists create my data
before I give my synthetic training data
to my model I want to run pre-trained
tests or pre-trained checks on my model
to make sure that the behavior of my
model is as expected
when I have a successful training run
with my synthetic data so all the
metrics are looking fine I can actually
start training on the real world data
and if I have done that and then I want
to check my training and validation
metrics as always but I think it's also
very useful to have some post-train
checks for example to check if you can
improve your data again and if
everything is going well of course this
is our dream we can finally add our
model to our model Zoo
so let's wrap up what what we have been
talking about today
um so I know we talked about debugging
on a very very high level
um and not go into the intricate details
because this can just be like a little
bit overwhelming if I just present a
list to you like oh this can go wrong
this can wrong this can go wrong usually
the issue we have is that we know
something is wrong but we don't quite
know where to look and if we have these
three components they will guide us a
little bit into which components we
should have
um yeah a deeper look to see if
something is going wrong here
so the first component was synthetic
data creation and what I really want you
to take from here is that your synthetic
data does not have to look like your
real data it can be super super simple
you really just want to use it for
debugging and not for generalization
the second thing I want you to remember
is pre-trained tests they don't have to
be complicated and you should also only
write them once you don't have to write
them for each project they can be as
easy as one function call so for example
here I have my model I test the model
everything fine I have my data loader I
test my data loader and then when I
start my training I should be able to
already rule out a plethora of bugs that
would be very hard for me to identify
otherwise
um the third thing I want you to
remember is post-train checks exist and
they can be very very helpful especially
if you didn't catch some bugs um that
happened before in your pipeline and
usually these metrics from post Trend
checks are also quite robust to any data
issues or can even help you identify
data issues
um yeah
so I hope this talk was useful for you
and of course I'll be super super happy
if I hear at least one story of a bug
that was that was caught with one of
these methods
um yeah after the talk also feel free to
contact me if you have anything to share
or any other recommendations
um if this was too high level for you I
also have on my GitHub some more
recommendations for more in-depth
reading for example some resources from
Andrew kopathy how to tune your hyper
parameters and also some more in-depth
views on how to create tests and checks
for your test Suites
yeah so then I would say let's call it
the web and I'd be happy to take some
questions from you
foreign
yes so thank you very much for the Deep
insights and the really helpful cookbook
we have some questions in slido so I'll
go through them from bottom to top but I
think some you have already answered
um so the first one is what library did
you use to create your amazing slides
thank you oh actually I think you should
uh I'm sorry yeah it's streamlined so I
was I was not scrolling down yeah it's
not it's very easy to use so I can
really recommend it yeah
okay so the second one is are there
options to check for non-obvious data
leakage like different images from the
same subject that should not be split
into train and test
um probably they are I would say you
have to
use some metadata if you have that
available
otherwise maybe some similarity scores
but I haven't like when I was
researching about this topic I haven't
come across anything here so maybe it
would be a good opportunity to build
something as well
are there any packages or libraries that
create synthetic data with noise like
outliers error points and such not just
perfect distributed data
I'm pretty sure they are I think there
are also several talks coming up about
synthetic data in the course of this
conference usually what I see when
you're creating synthetic data not for
debugging
um that you can input different
parameters so I will probably just play
around with the parameters of your
synthetic data creator for example if
you have a gun or variational
autoencoder just introduce a
distribution shift there
okay how about debugging issues at
training the model in a different
environment local versus cloud or a CPU
versus GPU
that's a very good question probably you
should make sure that you have a
transferable environment like poetry
Anaconda environment then I couldn't
imagine that so many issues are
occurring but in general I would
recommend that you make sure that your
model is bug free before scaling it
somewhere
okay which problem would you recommend
to start with meaning that there might
there might be more than one problem bug
in your code where is it better to start
I usually like to start with my data
because you did because I work at
computer vision and I like looking at
images
um and I would say 50 of the time
something is wrong with my data so
usually what I do is I just take a
single example and overfit on that and
if this is already not working
um I know something is in my model
structure but if this is working fine I
know okay I have to look at my data
because something is going wrong there
there's a question on which model was
used to predict probabilities for the
cleanlab case corrupt or original no
um oh I think the same model as before
um I think it had five or eight layers
so just to densely connected Network
it's also in the repository under the
torch examples if you want to have a
look
okay does it imply that packages should
appear soon that provide such generic
test Suites maybe you can create one
yourself
yeah this is a very interesting question
because from my um from my experience I
really like the setup with pre-trained
tests and post-train checks and there
are also some packages but they don't
seem to be in usage so much um so I'm
kind of like interested if there will be
a paradigm shift or P of people like
really pushing to use these packages and
create these packages
um or if yeah developers just enjoy
debugging by hand because I mean
something you can be very proud of if
you'll find your uh you're back without
without any help
um do you have any preference for test
Frameworks EG Pi test
in general yes pie test but I would say
for machine learning test Suite you
don't really need a specific testing
framework as you basically just building
one repository where you just have these
functions like test model or test loader
which basically just contain a certain
statements and here I think is also
quite handy to run them before the
training and not have like a separate
test run for example before you're
pushing somewhere
because then if you're still
experimenting you really catch your bugs
right before you perform your training
last question
um is Weight Watcher only working well
when you already have a pretty well
working model in your experience
um
no I would say that the main goal of
Weight Watcher is that it's
um that you can put any model into it
but in my experience it works quite well
for model comparison especially for
example if you want to compare
pre-trained models to see which one is
more suitable for your data and also if
you do model compression to check that
nothing has broken during your model
compression for example you've
compressed too much but in general
um yeah you can put any model into this
but I also don't have like a clear
recommendation of which metric is the
best so I would recommend to look at all
metrics as a whole okay time is up but
I'm sure you can come and approach Clara
and ask your questions in case you still
have any and thank you again for a very
fantastic talk
[Applause]